[Music]
in this video
we're going to walk through how to
manage user permissions for the payments
profile
tied to your google cloud billing
account if you're looking to give users
permission to update your payment method
billing address or payment contacts
you'll need to grant them permissions on
the payments profile associated with
your billing account
your billing account and payments
profile are separate entities that work
together
the billing account tracks the cost
incurred by all attached projects
and defines who pays for the resources
it is connected to a payments profile
which stores your payment instrument
information and defines how you pay for
charges
a payments profile can be linked to
multiple payment accounts across google
products such as google workspace google
cloud
google ads and more let's walk through
what permissions are available for the
payments profile
and how to update them get started by
heading into the cloud console
you can start on your organization or
any project home page
then head to the navigation menu in the
left hand pane
choose billing and then click manage
billing accounts
if you land in a billing overview page
which looks like this
you can navigate to manage billing
accounts by expanding the drop-down list
of billing accounts
now select the billing account navigate
to the payment settings page
you'll need to be a billing account
administrator or viewer on the billing
account to see this page
then under payments users click manage
payments users
note to be able to manage users and
permissions for the payments profile
you must yourself have managed users or
admin with
all permissions level access for the
payments profile
if you need this access please reach out
to the existing payments profile admins
here you can expand the details for an
existing user to update permissions
or to remove the user you can also click
to
add a new user you can set permissions
for users at several levels
each building on top of the prior
permissions
read access allows users to view the
payments profile
edit payments profile allows users to
view and edit the payment's profile
signup and purchase allows users to link
the payments profile with additional
google products
manage users allows users to add and
update users and permissions for this
payment's profile
admin with all permissions has all
current and future permissions
for the payments profile to set the
admin permission for a user
you must be an admin on this payment's
profile users with the manage
users permission can set only up to the
same permissions they are granted on
their user account
when you are finished setting up
permissions for the user click
invite for new users or save for
existing users
congratulations you can now manage
permissions for the payments profile
tied to your cloud billing account
head over to the documentation to check
out more details
you